with three years since announcement a
host of fake lore multiple teasers and
trailers a widely played network test
the involvement of world famous fantasy
author george rr martin not one but two
most anticipated game of the year awards
and the expectations of being the
spiritual successor to one of the most
popular franchises of the last decade
eldon ring is a primo candidate to be
overhyped now that might be dangerous to
say even as an obvious fromsoft fan i
could easily gain quite the ire for such
a suggestion considering souls fans
might be a bit too in love with from
software but in a world with dumpster
fire releases like no man's sky and even
recent poor releases like halo infinite
battlefield 2042 and of course cyberpunk
2077 it never hurts to take a second to
reconsider whether the hype and
expectations for a game are fully
merited
now we need a definition for overhyped
if we're going to have a discussion
about it if hype is the mix of fan
expectations and company marketing
before a game releases then a game would
be over hyped if these expectations
anticipations and marketing material
don't match up with the actual content
of the game when it's released a game is
overhyped if the hype that is the
expectations and marketing is too great
for the game itself or set in more
common way if the game doesn't live up
to the hype
eldon ring certainly does have quite the
share of fan expectations and exciting
marketing the list i stated at the start
of the video highlights that from
acclaimed game of thrones author to
beautiful cinematic trailers to multiple
anticipation awards to fans creating
rich and complex fake lore before any
information about the game actually
released the hype train for elton ring
is full steam ahead plus there are
content creators singing the game's
praises but here we run into a nuance in
the discussion of elden ring hype the
hype train may be full speed but for
overhype to be achieved this excitement
has to be to some degree unwarranted but
important to note content creator
comments on the game and even some of
the hype i mentioned before are not
solely made from expectations and
marketing some of it is made from time
spent with the game if the actual game
content is the cause of hype then it is
categorically harder for there to be
overhyped the mismatch of game content
and fan excitement if fans are excited
about what they actually see in the
actual game there's not really overhype
going on because that's what the actual
game is
content creators that have more alive
channels than me have been playing the
final build of the game and thousands of
people played a vertical slice of the
game in the network test at the end of
last year
now there are some complications here
content creators can be implicitly or
explicitly incentivized to give positive
reviews in exchange for the exclusive
access to the game they receive and the
network test only shows off a curated
vertical slice of the game that
developers can tailor to give a better
experience than the entire game might be
able to
so there is reason to believe the hype
is justified as some of it comes from
the game itself but there's also reason
to be a tad skeptical of some of the
pre-release discourse as i see it this
leads us to the developers themselves
from software to help us tell whether
this pre-release content is a
trustworthy source when it comes to
assessing the actual game taking a look
at the reputation and history of the
developing company can be illuminating
in the other examples of overhype that i
mentioned there was reason to fear over
hype given the status of the developers
the halo series has been on rough ground
really ever since 343 took the helm with
any successes being weighed down by
pretty glaring issues whether that be
the blandness of halo 4 or the story
trainwreck that was halo 5. essentially
every single recent battlefield has been
chiefly characterized by a mess of a
launch that sometimes takes years to
remedy though the lack of new content
and development misdirection of 2042 may
be too great even for the usual dice
post-launch fixer-upper and while cd
projekt red had a massive success with
the witcher 3 becoming poland's highest
valued company its history of smaller
successes in witcher 1 and 2 plus the
extremely different styles of the third
person witcher series versus the first
person cyberpunk setting did not provide
evidence that the company had the skills
to deliver a wildly impressive cyberpunk
game which was basically what the hype
for the game was
and of course no man's sky was made by
an indie dev team that had a single
digit staff not to mention the only game
they had developed previously was the
joe danger series
[Music]
so there wasn't a lot of reason to think
that that dev team could deliver what
the expectations and hype for no man's
sky were setting up to be
these examples of developers with so-so
histories illustrate how hype can shroud
past performance and mislead reasonable
expectations but this isn't really the
case with from software since demon
souls release in 2009 from software has
put out an impressive list of games that
speak to their ability to consistently
develop quality gaming experiences of a
certain type dark souls 1 2 3 bloodborne
and sakiro all rank highly both in
critical and general audience reviews
yes even dark souls 2 as well there are
multiple video game classics in their
catalog and essentially all of these
games build on pretty similar gameplay
and thematic elements whereas cd projekt
red shifted from third person fantasy to
first person shooter
cyberpunk from software have diligently
honed their craft in making games that
stand in their own genre one that they
essentially created from software has
shown that they're really good at making
souls like games and eldon ring for
better or for worse seems pretty
souls-like so in assessing eldon ring we
look to this history and compare it with
what kind of game eldin ring is and is
being presented as an elden ring is
being presented as essentially big dark
souls so from software's history of
creating fantastic souls like games
serves as pretty good evidence that they
are good at iterating on this kind of
game with this in mind it seems apparent
to me that we have good reason to think
the pre-release content of elden ring is
a decently fair source to learn and draw
conclusions about the actual game and if
that is the case then what i said
earlier probably obtains that the actual
game content is one of the main causes
for a lot of the hype so it is
categorically harder for there to be
overhyped with the decent amount of game
content we've seen both critically and
publicly and the decade plus evidence of
from software successfully making games
like this game i think it is a fair
conclusion to make that elden ring is
not over hyped and there's the answer to
the question in the video title and yes
unsurprisingly it follows better ridge's
law obviously people who are fan-gasming
about the perfect holiness of fromsoft
and those that think this game will
single-handedly cure all of life's woes
or at least all of gaming's woes are
probably putting too much stock in it
but the general attitudes of great
expectations for the game seem to be
decently justified and this video is
releasing with less than a week until
the game's release so we'll know the
actual answer soon enough it might seem
like it kind of defeats the purpose of
the question to ask it so soon before
the game comes out but i figured this
gave a good enough avenue to talk about
an interesting topic whether or not the
hype we give to something like a video
game is appropriate so i'm okay with the
little time and might be superficially
relevant the question of overhype ties
into our relationship with games as
products and as works of art and
discussing that is more important to me
than actually answering the question of
whether this one specific game is
overhyped or not i'm sure in the future
there will be games that gamers get way
too excited about get over hyped and
then get disappointed with the releases
that's going to happen irregardless of
whether or not videos like this are
there to be tools to get a better idea
of when something should be hyped when
something might be overhyped or not i
think it's just going to keep happening
because gamers are gamers
but it is still very interesting whether
or not a game that i'm very excited
about is worth getting so excited over
obviously that has some bearing on me
and anyone else who has invested heavily
into the game which is probably most of
you watching this video or people
watching my channel there's a decent
chance you're pretty into the soulsborne
kira series if you're watching my stuff
since a lot of the stuff that i've made
that's been popular has been soul's
content
well the main question of the video is
answered but if you feel like sticking
around to listen to my ramblings and how
this all relates to our relationship
with games as art feel free to
as we get really excited for the game to
release we are heavily interacting with
it as a product we are excited to get
this new shiny toy to play with and
enjoy we take some time off work or
cancel plans or block out time just to
enjoy this thing especially right when
it comes out is this commodification
something that prevents the game from
being a work of art can a work of art
also be such a mass-produced and
marketed product or what's the
importance of playing with or enjoying
the game right when it releases as
opposed to
six months after or a year after part of
it is surely that we want to play it and
enjoy it as soon as possible we're
excited about this new thing and when
it's out we're going to play it but
there's also an element of it being a
game and a multiplayer game that there's
an element of community and playing with
people and because there's pvp summoning
and fighting bosses with other people
it's important to play it when it's most
active so you get that whole experience
with all the other people and the other
covenants and factions and interactions
with those and that's not something that
we're going to get with a lot of other
works of art like movies or
music you can enjoy them with people but
it's with people and i don't want to say
a more superficial way but a less
categorically important way because part
of the core of the game for a game like
eldon ring or the soulsborne series more
broadly other than zakiro is that
community aspect of playing the game
with other people so other people are
online with you and discovering things
with the community because that's
historically how the lore and story and
deeper meanings of these kinds of games
get revealed it's people interacting and
talking about the stuff going on here
which to some degree is something that
can happen with music and movies
discussion afterwards um but it's just
not as categorically important of a
thing as with a game that has a
multiplayer feature and the question of
whether a work of art can be such a
mass-produced and mass-marketed thing
is a question that comes up somewhat but
not as much with these other kinds of
art that i've been talking about like
great albums and films sure plenty of
extremely popular and mass-marketed pop
music and blockbusters might seem more
product than art but plenty of genuine
work of art albums and kino films get
lots of marketing people get excited
about their releases and may block out
special time just to experience them in
the exact same way as with a game as i
said the importance of experiencing it
right when it comes out might not be as
important as with a multiplayer game but
people still interact with it in a
similar way in terms of blocking out
time and wanting to see it as early as
they can wanting to see a cool movie on
opening night games don't have the same
social prestige as great films or music
but the experience people have with them
in this way or how they interact with
them in terms of excitement before
release or hype if you will are pretty
similar and i think that's basically it
in terms of ramblings most of that was
not as scripted as the rest of the video
um the rest of the video i had a very
explicit script and this is more bullets
but i thought it was interesting to talk
about and games as art is something
that's very important to me as well so a
little avenue to explore that to explore
the community around games especially
for games like
dark souls or the soul series eldon ring
from soft games is pretty cool and
important and especially in my
interaction with the games like the last
game that i played very intensely of the
soulsborne series was dark souls 3 and a
lot of that experience was interacting
with people on reddit and online to
discuss the different things about the
game and make videos and have people
comment on the videos and all that
discussion going on so it's a very
important aspect to me and i'm excited
for it in eldon ring and it all builds
into the kind of hype equation in
question as well so i hope you enjoyed
this video and if you want to see elden
ring lore and all that gucci elden ring
content i'm going to be posting it so
stick around
bye